Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today, I'm going to explain an episode called
"Nosedive" from the British science fiction
series "Black Mirror."
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie sets in a possible near-future scenario,
in which society is dictated by a rating system
ranging from 1 to 5 stars.
In this kind of society, each individual gives
a "rating" to one another, depending on their interactions.
The social and economic position that one
has in this kind of society, is determined
by that person's overall rating, there are
benefits for those with 4 and 5 overall ratings.
On the other hand, those with 1 to 3 overall
ratings, receive little to no benefits.
For this reason, inside this society, one
must always act positively, or else they will
get a low score.
The episode begins with a woman jogging in
a suburban village, while holding a phone.
The woman, Lacie Pound, is looking at her
phone, inspecting what seems to be postings
from other people, which she gives a rating
of 5 stars each.
After jogging, she looks at the bathroom mirror
and practices all kinds of giggles and laughs.
In her eyes, a faint light can be seen, indicating
some sort of technology.
Lacie lives with her brother Ryan, who has
a lower approval rating than her, and she
is eager to move out.
Lacie then leaves the house to have lunch.
Outside, she buys a coffee with a cookie.
As a response, she gives the clerk and everyone
else around her a 5-star rating; everyone
else in turn gives her a 5-star rating as
well.
Lacie can see each person's overall rating
and information through her eyes, and other
people can see it as well, including her overall
rating of 4.2 stars and other information.
She tries the cookie and coffee—which she
did not like—and takes a picture of it afterwards,
which she posted online, despite her not liking
both.
The picture receives multiple 5-star ratings,
and her overall rating goes up slightly.
She goes to work after that.
In the elevator, she meets a woman that she
frequently interacts with.
However, the details of their conversation
are based only on each other's posts and information,
which they could access through their phones
and eyes.
After that, Lacie goes to her table to work.
There, she meets a co-worker whose overall
rating is low; her co-worker is giving off
free smoothies to raise his rating.
Upon taking one and drinking it, she receives
low rating.
She notices this and decides not to interact
with him anymore.
Soon, she learns that her house is being bought,
so she decides to look for a new, more expensive
house to live in.
She goes to "Pelican Cove" in an exclusive
neighbourhood.
It is an expensive place, but she learns that
she needs to raise her 4.2 rating to 4.5 for
a discount on this luxury apartment.
She also learns from a consultant that she
has to socialize with people outside her circle,
particularly those of higher ratings, to raise
her ratings quickly.
She tries at first to act friendly to all
people, but only receives average ratings.
She then sees her co-worker with a low rating,
but he cannot enter the building this time
because his low rating does not qualify.
Lacie's co-worker asks for her help, but Lacie
ignores him to preserve her rating.
Later, Lacie uploads a photograph of Mr. Rags,
a ragdoll that she and her childhood friend made together.
Her childhood friend, Naomi, sees this picture,
which prompted her to contact Lacie.
Naomi informs her that she is getting married,
and she wants Lacie, her oldest friend, to
be her maid of honor, which Lacie delightedly
accepts.
Naomi has a rating of 4.8, and has many upper-class
friends and lives on an exclusive and idealistic island.
Lacie believes if she nails a perfect maid
of honour speech, she will be flooded with
enough 5-star ratings, to pull her approval
up to the 4.5 she needs.
Her brother finds it strange that Naomi is
asking Lacie as her maid of honor, when their
relationship was not that great in the past.
Lacie insists that Naomi is her friend, and
that her being the maid of honor would definitely
raise her overall rating.
Because of this, Lacie prepares for her speech
at the upcoming wedding, even practising one
last time before leaving for the wedding.
Her brother stops her, wanting her to think
about this obsession with ratings, but Lacie
already made up her mind.
This leads to an argument between them, ending
in giving each other a low rating.
On the way to the airport, Lacie receives
low ratings from two incidents, dropping her
rating from 4.2 to 4.1.
First, she accidentally bumps into a woman
holding a cup of coffee, spilling her coffee;
and second, the taxi driver gives her a low
rating for being so loud while talking in
the phone.
What is worse however, is that her original
flight has been cancelled, and she needs 4.2
rating to get a seat on another.
She insists on taking the seat, causing a
scene that results in her overall rating going down.
As a precautionary measure, the airport security
guard turns her overall rating to 3, which
would last for 24 hours.
Additionally, she also receives, as punishment,
a devastating "double damage" effect on her
rating, which means that all downvotes will
incur a double multiplier.
Because she is going to be late to the wedding,
she decides to rent a car.
However, she has a low rating and cannot avail
of a higher quality car, so she has no other
choice, but to rent a car of a much older
model.
While driving, she practices her speech as
the maid of honor, but her trip is cut short
when the car needs to be charged.
She learns that the car, being an old model,
needs an adapter to charge.
Because she cannot charge it, she leaves it,
deciding instead to walk and hitchhike.
Because she has a low rating of 3, cars avoid
her, but eventually, a truck stops by and
offers to help.
At first, Lacie is hesitant, seeing that the
driver has a low rating, but she agrees later on.
While driving, the truck driver, an older
woman, asks Lacie where she was going and
why she was going there.
Lacie tells her that she is the maid of honor
in an exclusive wedding.
The truck driver tells her that she was once
like her: she had an overall rating of 4.6,
and she was always aiming to receive a high
rating in the belief that it will lead to a good life.
However, her husband got cancer, and she did
everything for her husband, even taking him
to an exclusive hospital, but he was rejected
because his rating was deemed not high enough.
After her husband died, she decided to become
honest with everything, learning in the process
that her so-called "friends" did not like
her honesty that much, so she ended up having a low rating.
However, she says she feels much freer without
obsessing over ratings.
Lacie replies that unlike the old woman who
got nothing to lose, she still got something to live for.
The trip takes all night, and in the morning,
Lacie is awakened by the truck driver, telling
her that they must part ways because she is
heading in another direction.
As a parting gift, the truck driver informs
Lacie that she placed alcohol in her bag.
Then Lacie goes to a nearby toilet and practices
her speech again.
She overhears two women talking about a convention;
to Lacie's surprise, the convention is near
the wedding reception.
After pretending that she is heading to the
same convention, she takes a ride with some
cosplayers in a van.
Soon after, Naomi contacts her again, telling
Lacie not to go to the wedding anymore.
She has heard that her overall rating had
gone down to 2, and that she cannot have someone
like that at her wedding.
The only reason she invited Lacie was that
it would add her ratings exponentially.
Lacie, surprised and heartbroken by this,
learns that she is just a number to Naomi;
likewise, Naomi responds that she knew Lacie's
intention all along, and that is just to accumulate
high ratings in the wedding.
In actuality, both of them never saw each
other as a friend, but rather as a tool to
gain higher ratings.
However, despite this, Lacie still wants to
go to the wedding and deliver her speech,
to which Naomi responds with a stern "no."
This doesn’t stop Lacie; she decides to
trespass and crash the wedding reception.
The cosplayers left her behind after she tells
them that she doesn't know about the convention at all.
She drinks the alcohol that the truck driver
gave her and stops a few cars, but eventually,
she sees a four-wheeler bike and borrows it.
She finally reached the reception by sneaking
at the back, but not before falling into a
swamp and getting dirty.
After dressing up, Lacie—all dirty and drunk—delivers
her speech to the audience, who in response,
all gave her a rating of 1.
She reveals that she wants to be like Naomi:
someone beautiful, with high ratings, a good
circle of friends, and a good life.
She is forcefully removed from the reception
and is afterwards put in jail.
The technology in her eyes is removed, and,
for the first time, she sees the world without
any rating of any kind.
In the adjacent cell, a man is looking at
her; Lacie tries to check his information
out of habit, but of course, she sees nothing
as the technology has been removed from her.
The man insults her, and Lacie replies with
an insult as well.
Without any fear of rating, they insult each
other to their hearts' content.
The episode ends with both of them shouting
at each other, their anger and frustration
eventually turning to happiness at this newfound
freedom.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on notifications, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank you for watching.